Avez-vous suivi vos cours de langues à l'école ?
Le mec s'en va, le mec s'en fout
Eh ben j'espère que oui parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous allez en avoir besoin.
C'est un jeu assez rigolo, on est sur un site, il va nous dire des mots
et on va devoir, à l'oral, et on va devoir deviner la langue.
Je sais par exemple qu'il y a des gens qui ont beaucoup de mal à reconnaître
Le chinois, du coréen, du japonais et pas moi! Et je vais vous le prouver aujourd'hui
Par contre, il y a beaucoup de langues sur cette planète que je n'ai probablement jamais entendu
Mais on va faire ce qu'on peut !
*Langue étrangère*
*rires*
Attend, le mec a dit Osaka, Osaka c'est une très grosse ville au japon mec
du coup, je me suis dis c'est du japonais
Japonais un peu, euh, un peu danois quand même tu vois
c'est bien évidemment du Danois mec
* éclat de rire*
oh non je me suis pété de ouf
oh le karma
ah j'ai hésité entre les deux en tout cas ni français ça c'est clair ni japonais !
C'est du urdu alors c'est du urdu bah oui il reste plus que le urdu.
*langue étrangère*
alors, c'est pas de l'italien
Et c'est tout ce que j'en ai tiré comme conclusion , c'est nul.
P*tain mais, c'est quoi ça ?
*langue étrangère*
corsa a traverche ma
Et je fais le signe italien alors que ce n'est pas du tout italien.
*langue étrangère*
*pet* (#SqueezieImmature)
Ça me stresse, mec
Est-ce que c'est du roumain
p't-etre on peut appeller Cyprien pour savoir
j'aimerais bien nan mais il est en vacance là il est en vacances il pourra pas répondre
Fait ch*er !
ou alors c'est du Javanes ou du Tamil mec chais même pas que c'est  mais en tout cas, vieux. C'est pas italien.
P't-etre Javanais ?
Ohh *tain c'était du roumainnnn CYPRIENNNNNN!!!!!
donc le roumain, on dirait un mélange d'allemand et d'italien ça donne le romain
*langue étrangère*
C'est du Russe
Ah bah voilà, voilà un jour on va avoir bon p*tain
*langue étrangère*
OOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHH OOOOH
ALORS DEVINEZ DEVINEZ Devinez !!
*pet* (immature/20)
*rire* *tain maiis...
Mec chuis en train de pourrir de l'intérieur c'est terrible.
*rire*
et ça c'est le 3ème youtuber de France qui ... qui rigole pendant 2 minutes parce qu'il a pété...
Alors, vous avez le choix, est-ce que c'est de l'Arabe, est-ce que c'est du chinois, est-ce que c'est du japonais ou est-ce que c'est du Swalalala
Ou est-ce que c'est du Swahili
*langue étrangère*
Bon c'est du Japonais, fin du suspens,
On reconnait beaucoup parce que ya beaucoup de ke tu sais
kikoroko nikarake ko guseymakchta hayo come ma ha voilà
alors est-ce du Danois de l'ossetic de l'urdu ou de l'uzbek!
*langue étrangère*
mustafa
Aaaah j'ai envie de croire au danois encore une fois
*TAIN c'est de l'usbec ?
*tain mec j'ai jamais entendu
Ah meec mais c'est super duuuur
meec c'est super dur ! On dirait un mélange de de mille langues
Rhaaa c'est dur, hein !
Vas-y ! On le refait mec !
Attends, c'est génial ce jeu mec.
*langue étrangère*
C'est pas vietnamien déjà, c'est pas vietnamien.
Ukrainien ?
Oh! P*tain c'était le telegu.
Hé ! Mec c'est chaud là euuuh gros je connais même pas
*langue étrangère*
*Il essaye de répéter*
Oh P*tain j'adore.
*langue étrangère*
Ça ça chante.
J'aime bien.
Mais je trouve que l'italien, c'est encore  plus beau.
OOOh bah attendez, petite anecdote juste pour rire un coup.
Est-ce que vous jouez à Overwatch?
Vous voyez l'ulti en deux celui qui fait yougawatekiKARUUUUU
Vous voyez bien ?
Et bah écoutait bien je sais pas pourquoi je suis tombé sur cette vidéo ou y'a l'ulti en 1000 langues différentes,
Et au moment où il l'a dit en espagnol, j'ai chialé de rire.
Je sais pas c'était plus fort que moi...
En fait je trouve que c'est une belle langue, mais dans les situations hyper sérieuses, j'y arrive pas y croire je sais pas pourquoi
Donc, dans plein de pays c'est ça, c'est la VO
Que même nous en France c'est cette voix là qu' on a
yougawatetikiKARUUU
et maintenant, ça change.
yougawazikyoukyaRUUU
*rire*
Les gens, en japonais... pourtant le japonais c'est une trop belle langue mais *utain il lui ont sorti une voix,mon gars
On dirait il a 80 piges
yougawatekukoraERRR
Là, la Corée, ils ont géré ils ont géré. La voix est trop cool.
déteraconneteboleramigosshenemiGOOS
*rires*
Non mais mec! Quand je revois, ça me fait rire!
En fait, chuis tellement habitué au yougawatetikikARUUU tsais!
et là, il fait vraiment eldragonesedonefwego
Ah désolé... Ça se trouve, personne me suit dans ce délire,
et euh  je suis seuuuuul auuu mooonde.
On n'est pas à l'abri.
Oon. Suivant
Alors chinois, finnish, swahili thaï. *utain...
*langue étrangère*
c'est pas chinois. J'dirai finish ou swahili.
OOOOOOOOOOOH MON DIEU!!! MAIS LE MEC EST UN TITAN!
Sans les muscles... mais un titan!
J'adore ce jeu! Je pourrais y jouer pendant des jours durant.
Comme ma prof de sport. Elle s’appelait Mme Durand.
Nan mais voilà! On fait des big up 6 ans après, voilà. Mme Durant, c'est pour toi
Alors quel langage c'est ?
*Langue étrangère*
Bah anglais. Elle a dit seven thousand sept mille
bah chuis bilangue excusez-moi j'ai reconnu en moins d'une seconde pardon excusez moi PARDON!
Hindi, orssetic hindi hindi quoi. Hindi game comme les jeux sur lesquels on fait des vidéos ,ou ....
*rire forcé*
J'rigole pas, c'est faux
*langue étrangère*
Portuguais nan ?
NAAAAN *UTAIN pardon
Y'avait beaucoup de " ch " comme les portugais dans les schtromph, quand ils parlent.
Quand je restais au portuguais NAN MAIS JE LE DIS ! Quand je vais au restaurant portuguais une fois par an, la table d'à coté, je les entendais dire trois phrases et ma conclusion, c'est que y'a beaucoup de "ch" dans le portugais
Mais c'était pas ça...
Donc chhh...
bengali danois portugais ou telugu.
Est-ce que je vais pouvoir me racheter auprès de mes abonnés portugais qui me font actuellement profondément la gueule
*langue étrangère*
Nan. C'est pas portugais.
Parce que c'est BENGALI!
Sans prévenir, il est arrivé, il a dit : c'est bengali.
Arabe, hausa, coréen, ukrainian.
*langue étrangère*
euuuh oulah *utain là mec euh...
C'est soit ça, soit ça : Hausa
Eh! vous avez compris la blague
Attends je suis doué sur ça. Nan, mais elle était bien. Ferme ta *ueule, ferme ta *ueule.
*langue étrangère*
Arrête de m’engueuler déjà commence par ne pas m’engueuler si tu veux que je devine ta langue.
J'pense pas que ce soit arabe... pour moi, c'est Hausa
Merci à tous mes potes rebeux qui m'ont montré la voie en me sortant des gros starfoulah et des wallah
J'en ai tiré les conclusions qui fallait, c'est tout !
j'suis un *onnard...
j'adore mec! *utain c'est trop bien!!
En plus, ça t’entraîne à essayer de reconnaître les syllabes ! Donc c'est vraiment pas mal en fait.
norvégiens portugais tamil thaï.
*langue étrangère*
PORTUGUAIS!
On voit le mec qui met bien les portugais et qui mange à leur resto souvent, ou pas?!
Parce que la bouffe portugaise elle est *Bruit de bisous*
écoutez.
*langue étrangère*
En fait nan y'a pas du tout "ch".
En tout cas, ça a l'air d’être dur
vous savez, les langues, c'est plus ou moins dur à apprendre selon, euh j'sais plus c'est quoi le terme, mais en gros y'a des syl... par exemple,
en français, on a 80 % de syllabes en communs avec le japonais,
donc quand t'apprendras le japonais, tu vas pas trop le galérer à parler parce que tu sauras déjà dire les syllabes.
Alors q'ya des langues comme le portugais où c'est des syllabes qui a pas en français pratiquement c'est plein de syllabes qu'elle disait, j'arrivais même pas à
savoir c'était quelles lettres qui étaient collées.
"Parce qu'elle n'arrivait pas à trouver des balayages à Londres!" Eh bien oui! "parce que j'ai du mal a croire, mais euh...
et je lui ai dit en rigolant, bah voila il faut faire 20 000 km pour..."
C'est *atard de faire des phrases isolées comme ça,
quand tu la comprends, c'est vraiment ridicule.
Je me suis toujours demandé phonétiquement, quand un étranger nous entendait parler mais qui parle pas français,
comment ça sonnait. Par exemple, nous quand un italien parle, on kiffe.
Mais ça se trouve, quand un américain entend un italien parler, il n'aime pas du tout. On n'en sait rien.
Et j'aimerais trop pouvoir, pendant 4 secondes, ne plus parler français pour savoir ce que ça fait d'entendre du français,
mais sans le comprendre. Est-ce que ça sonne bien ou pas. Voilà.
C'est un délire bizarre! Je pense qu'on finit là dessus, voilà! Maintenant que je viens de perdre tous mes abonnés,
c'est très bien!
Et voila les amis, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo! N'hésitez pas à aimer si elle vous a plu!
Ne faites jamais ça avec votre pantalon, c'est fortement déconseillé, hein.
On se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo! Merci d'avoir regardé, c'était super cool!
Je vous mets le lien du jeu dans la description et n'hésitez pas à y jouer, ça vous entraînera, c'est super sympa, et même,
ça me fait plaisir de me dire que, maintenant, dans la rue j'arriverais peut-être un peu plus à savoir euh... d'où viennent les touristes.
Ouais, c'est un peu nul en fait...
*rire*
Allez! A tout' dans une prochaine vidéo!
Merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien!
Au revoir!
*Outro*